foreign
[Music]
for Monday March 27th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the things chat Bots with artificial
intelligence can do are pretty
impressive write a sonnet pass the lsats
carry on a conversation about weekend
plants but Publishers of online content
the information used to train AI chat
Bots like chat GPT are beginning to
think about whether they should be
compensated and what their legal options
are that's according to people familiar
with a meeting organized by the news
media Alliance a publishing trade group
so what's behind their concerns and what
can these Publishers do teach hege
covers media and marketing for the Wall
Street Journal and is with me now hey
Keach thanks for joining me great to be
here why are Publishers upset Publishers
are looking at the results that are
coming out of chat Bots like chat GPT
and seeing that some of those answers
look pretty familiar right and they're
concerned that it's their copyrighted
content that has been used to train
these things that is now producing
something particularly once it becomes
merged with something like a search
engine like Bing that might make people
less likely to actually click on their
links when the answers to certain things
are surfaced are these similar to
concerns that artists have expressed
about seeing their work or similar
versions to their work created by air
generators yes it's basically exactly
the same thing but what's really
interesting is that the legal questions
for images are sort of more evolved than
they are for print or for text so there
are active lawsuits right now happening
around images but we have not seen one
yet for pros so what steps are
Publishers taking now so Publishers are
really having meetings having working
groups meeting as part of their trade
group and also having internal meetings
just trying to understand first of all
what their options are what their legal
rights are what kind of legal actions
they can take and should take as well as
what their commercial opportunities are
so there have already been some cases in
which companies like openai have done
deals for content for AI training like
for example with Shutterstock which is
like a stock photography and images and
video company they will license certain
images or they've even said very
specialized information like science
information so it's a delicate balance
because the Publishers know that there
very well might be a Marketplace out
there and is already the beginnings of
one where they could do commercial deals
and have their content paid for to be
fed into these chat Bots are there any
specific Publishers that we know are
having these kinds of talks so Reddit is
in talks with Microsoft about the use of
its data in AI training Reddit has had a
very special role I would say in this
ecosystem it was reported in the early
days of open AI that they were a
significant source of the data that was
used to train the AI and early days you
know there are many many other sources
but the folks there are having active
conversations about compensation and
about what's right going forward that's
according to people familiar with the
matter what do companies like Microsoft
and Google say about Publishers concerns
that they're not getting compensated
correctly for the use of their
information Microsoft and Google
generally respond by not really engaging
with the copyright question itself and
saying that our search products present
a value exchange to Publishers
Publishers give us the right to crawl
their content and we give them traffic
in exchange and that's kind of a fair
value Exchange in itself which doesn't
really address the copyright questions
now in a broader way the tech industry
in general has claimed that tech
companies have the right to use
Publishers data to train their AI models
under this carve out and copyright law
called fair use and fair use says that
in certain circumstances you can take
someone's content and use it without
permission the circumstances are
complicated they're sort of a
case-by-case basis but that has been
what the tech industry generally has
said they have the right to do and open
AI the maker of chat GPT which is
probably what most listeners are
familiar with how do they respond so we
had an interview with Sam Altman the CEO
of openai and you know he said yes they
do do a lot through fair use so a lot of
the content that has gone into training
chat gbt they believe they Acquired and
used under this carve out of fair use
but he also said that they have done
deals to pay for certain kinds of
content I mean there has been this issue
search and and Publishers for a while
Publishers being concerned that users go
on search they type in their question or
the information that they're looking for
and they can see it right on the search
page already and don't necessarily click
on to a Publisher's website is this AI
issue making that problem worse in their
eyes yes there is a lot of concern that
the most recent version of Bing that is
powered by open AI is chat GPT is
pushing that even farther so there are
citations in the Bing version there are
links to Publishers but they're like
little tiny almost academic footnotes at
the bottom and the chance that someone
is going to click on that doesn't seem
super high in the eyes of many
Publishers who've taken a look at it
however I should also say that they're
really sort of
separate issues here right one is
whether the tech companies have the
right to use the Publisher's data at all
in AI training and the other is how
should the tech companies design their
search products in such a way that
fairly delivers traffic to publishers
if the Publishers feel like their data
is being used inappropriately or you
know without giving them correct
compensation do they actually have any
recourse or are they just hoping that
Microsoft Google other platforms make
deals with them well they do have the
recourse of removing their content from
being able to be crawled by either
Google or Microsoft right you can put
txt on the end of your URL and you can
sort of remove yourself from being
crawled however that's not an ideal
solution for many many Publishers
because they do rely on the traffic that
the search engines bring so that's why
they're looking at a full range of
options including some legislation
that's been kicking around Congress for
several years that would allow them to
band together to negotiate with tech
companies because the power imbalance is
so extreme between any one publisher and
these giant tech companies okay that's
wsj reporter keycheggy thanks so much
for joining us Keach thank you and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
but a quick note on AI before we close
the show we still want to hear your
questions about generative artificial
intelligence AI programs like chat gbt
Microsoft's new Bing and Google's new
Bard we're going to answer them on an
upcoming show do you want to know about
their capabilities or how they might
change our lives
leave us a voicemail with your AI
question at
415-439-6482 or email us a voice
recording to tnb wsj.com we look forward
to hearing from you
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]